cuatro puntos principales primero dijo
que las pérdidas iban a ser pagadas por
el gobierno de Estados Unidos es decir
los las personas que hayan depositado
dinero en el silicón Bank Pues iban a
ser reembolsadas completamente esto con
el objetivo de darle seguridad a el
sistema bancario estadounidense dijo
además que los fondos no vendrán de las
de las contribuyentes Es decir de las
personas que pagan los impuestos este
rescate a este banco y a otro banco en
Nueva York no saldrá de la plata Que los
contribuyentes pagan año a año sino de
un fondo un fondo de seguros que los
bancos privados pues anualmente ponen en
ese fondo para precisamente tratar de
salvar sistemas financieros en caso de
que algún banco se llegue a este punto
de casi bancarrota por otro lado dice
que la administración de este banco y de
los bancos y el Nueva York que también
pues va a ser parte de este programa de
rescate la administración Es decir todos
los directivos de estos bancos van a ser
despedidos precisamente porque pues
dicen que de haber llegado acá es porque
hubo una administración no muy adecuada
para precisamente llegar a la crisis a
la que llevó a que estos bancos tengan
que ser rescatados por el gobierno
estadounidense Así que la administración
y los directivos de estos bancos van a
ser despedidos Y por último Pues dijo
que se empezará una investigación para
saber cuál fue el motivo que llevó a que
el banco el silicon Valley que guardaba
la plata de muchos inversionistas y de
muchas empresas pues haya tenido que
llegar a este punto lo que están
diciendo analistas acá en Estados Unidos
es que pues este banco el banco silicon
Valle y el otro banco en Nueva York al
cual el gobierno de Estados Unidos va a
terminar respaldando pagándole a todas
las personas que tenían su dinero ahí
depositado no eran bancos grandes que
representaban un riesgo para la economía
o para el sistema financiero de Estados
Unidos es decir lo que están diciendo y
precisamente profesores de de economía
de la Universidad de Chicago Es que la
quiebra de estos bancos no iba a
representar una crisis económica en
Estados Unidos pues Cristóbal creo que
ella me adelanta lo que decía Joe sobre
este anuncio particularmente importante
sobre las inversiones ahí le pregunto si
habrá algo más que agregar
Sí el gobierno de Estados Unidos además
dijo que va a crear todo un programa
precisamente y va a aumentar la
legislación y La regulación a los bancos
para que no se llegue a este punto lo
que preocupa también es que precisamente
este fondo al cual se recurre para pues
salvar a estos bancos o a estas personas
que tenían su dinero en estos bancos
queda Ya pues prácticamente y líquido y
entonces lo que va a hacer el gobierno
es crear un programa de préstamos con la
reserva federal y con el tesoro de
Estados Unidos que pues el leve más
seguridad a los clientes y más seguridad
al sistema bancario estadounidense
porque recordemos que pues efectivamente
si tiene un efecto dominó que si alguno
de estos bancos medianos cae a
bancarrota pues entonces esto derivará
en que muchas otras personas empiecen a
sacar su dinero de las instituciones
financieras que fue lo que ocurrió
Precisamente en el banco
y pues genere más pánico económico
entonces lo que trato de hacer el
gobierno Obviamente fue aquí evitar ese
pánico económico salvando organizaciones
financieras medianas que aunque
analistas digan que no ponían en riesgo
el sistema financiero el banco Pues el
gobierno quiere evitar cualquier tipo de
ruido de Cara a a a a a a a a a esto que
acaba de ocurrir en Estados Unidos en
silicon va